let's do the right thing it's one of my
favorite projects to work on and I think
one of the things I love most about
working with Spike was just the ability
to kind of work out the box and always
you know giving people an opportunity
like never assuming someone would be
able to do what they do just giving them
opportunity to be all they could be and
pushing the envelope and I remember
spike telling me about Rosie and it was
Mike's birthday party and we were
partying at punky reggae punky reggae
woman's right back in the date day and
Matt Robinson was spinning and Rosie was
dancing and on top of a speaker on top
of a speaker doing the button doing the
but it's true but she auditioned for
that movie in my house remember that she
had and she had no acting experience but
it didn't matter because it was all
about instinct and what a person could
convey with their truth and I think
that's what we always went into casting
you know your movies with that concept
and wanting people just to bring
everything they could bring whatever
that was and we discovered some gems as
a result a question for Richard you know
the stuff between you and Mookie and the
stuff between you and John and stuff you
know how much of that was you you guys
was the script and how much is improv
spike you know me like the stuff you
mean John was was Sol's are there huh I
was out there in this girl I know that
but most of it was improvised right the
scene in the back room and it closet the
closet
I remember something happened remember
the the camera ran out of film
during the first take and I didn't I was
not expecting what John was gonna do he
came out of me pretty strong so I was so
happy when the camera broke I'm not the
cameras well you ran out of film but
John was very pissed off but I was like
it was a good moment for me to like
gather my thoughts
ah that's what John's gonna do huh but
but I wanted you know about the Nation
of Islam they were the security Preston
was saying and I told spike this is like
I'm a friendly guy I'm a nice guy and I
tried to make friends with everybody so
I was like these guys I'm gonna make
friends with him every single morning
there was about five around where we
changed so I'd say hello to every single
one and never once did I get a response
about four weeks of that I gave up oh my
god stronger than I am but then yeah but
what about other stuff with you between
you and Mookie when you guys walk out
and you got the chart the chalk drawings
and everything and stuff oh yeah that
was a spike the moment before we started
do the scene he said I you you're a good
and fan and I'm a Clemmons fan I thought
it was so clever because yeah that's not
expected yeah about that huh about
Clements and Dwight good and we were
wrong about that one man your mouth gum
how why how what the hell that careful
take a mic well
Spike Lee actually liberated me from
Repertory Theater
I was doing Ionesco and Dickens and
Pinter and Shakespeare at this place
called the Guthrie Theater and I went to
see this film called she's got to have
it and I sat through it twice and I said
I got to find out who this guy is and
what he's doing next and this wonderful
woman
Robbie Reed organized a cattle call
audition for school days and I told
dirty joke and I sang a song and spike
felt that I was demented enough to be
one of the fraternity pledges in school
days Gamma Phi Gamma and so when the
word came out that he was doing this
other thing I thought that I should be
able to contribute something but there
was nothing in it for me but spike was
good enough to give me a draft of the
script which was prefaced by a quote
from Malcolm X so let's really write
that yeah there was no character in the
movie for you
there was nothing written for you in the
movie no there was right no but my
brother was kind enough to give me a
draft of the script okay which was
probably a story I'm to buy a Malcolm X
we're doing you know James Brown Bobby
Byrd happened on Wars long again the
idea
cuz some people don't get that long long
long time ago a long time ago look what
I'm saying go ahead so he said take it
home read it and see what you come up
with we'll meet in the morning
and I came back to spike in the morning
and he was talking to the late great
Robin Harris mr. Martin Lawrence who
made his film debut and do the right
thing and I came up with the idea of
this guy who walked up and down the
street trying to sell personally
colorized photographs of Malcolm X
shaking hands with Martin Luther King
and whenever I had seen that photograph
it always shocked me because the popular
propaganda about these men of course is
that they were diametrically opposed
what you can see in the flash of that
bulb that they had true love and respect
for each other
now the the image of Malcolm and Martin
is a standard piece of international
iconography and of course the film was
the first date of our president and his
wife if they are going to see Driving
Miss Daisy it might have turned out
differently and it was a tremendous
opportunity and and to work with people
like the late great Robin Harrison
certainly at the lake great miss movie
DVD
Robin has an IV game and Ossie Davis is
there Paul Benjamin Nana please for
Robin Harris Ruby King Ossie Davis